what's up everybody welcome back to the
podcast it's just me and addy chilling
out once again last time you were here
you dropped like so much wisdom bombs
and like interesting insights and all
that kind of stuff he's like you're the
one who like coined the whole like the
saga of corridor
as like a story that in and of itself is
like a thing that drives the channel
which is really interesting because a
lot of people brought that up afterwards
oh wow no idea
man
i have nothing but love for for you and
your audience and everything you you
guys have pulled off and i
think i call you every once in a while
and i'm like man
i wish i had a family
like a work family
yeah man look i've got a great team
around me i i love my
my squad
yeah you have an army
right
i'm squad goals you're you're like ready
to like [ __ ] invade some
yeah it's just all special forces
[Laughter]
yeah man
it's pretty crazy like the amount of
like
stuff happening at corridor now compared
to like corridor from three years ago or
four years ago we have about 20 people
in the office right now it's like we had
like 12
3 years ago
it's nuts like just there's always
things happening and it's at the point
now where like projects happen that i'm
not like on top of
so like they just come out and it's like
wow that's cool that's what it must feel
like to be somebody that watches the
channel i mean
it makes sense you hitched your wagon so
to speak to the internet yeah and as the
internet uh continues to go from
how it was perceived when we were
growing up like a like a kind of a geeky
nerdy thing for hackers right i mean uh
to to being what it is today which is
a district like the the most epic
global distribution channel ever yeah
and uh you know it's taken
most of the not most of it i shouldn't
say most of it's taking it's
continuously taking more and more ad
dollars from linear media yeah and that
just the trickle-down effect of that is
going to
lead to corridor digital abundance yeah
it i mean it's kind of it's happening
little by little just i mean the fact
that we've grown so much the past few
years which is weird it's like
everybody's like oh yeah the internet
youtube it's like it's so cutting edge
now it's like it's so old news it's like
why aren't you on tick tock now
but you know it's like jake talks about
how
like fortunate we are to be in a world
where distribution is free you know it's
like right now when everybody's like
dealing with supply chains and like
issues with china and like getting stuff
across the ocean it's like it's
effortless and easy for us to be like
here everybody have our product and it
costs us nothing to give it to you and
you get it instantly
it's like what a what a spot to be in
yeah yeah yeah it's um
just i i just have kind of grab massive
amounts of gratitude for for this this
time we were born in this time that we
exist in that's crazy
you know people turning into the podcast
right now perhaps they don't know who
you are they haven't seen the other
podcasts we did together like right
could you did you introduce yourself to
like the anonymous
audience on the other side yeah i i've
i've um
i didn't know how to introduce myself
for years
because there have been like phases of
my career in my life and there's also
like this huge disconnect between who i
am as a as a human being and then like
the content i make right
like
um
and then people meet me and they're like
you're nothing like how oh yeah yeah i'm
playing a character like i'm you know
a character but um you know i would say
there's
a few phases of of my career i i started
off making
or being part of the hollywood ecosystem
right so that that led
to me being
a part of the process
and that meant being one of the
producers of
several large theatrical release
films
i
grew dissatisfied with that
um and i was unable to kind of
articulate why at the time but i
realized it was because
i wanted to be working with intellectual
property the the
the
the characters i loved and the the games
and
[Music]
cartoons that i loved growing up
and um
i wanted to be an auteur again i didn't
didn't i lacked the self-awareness to to
say this so i was just kind of doing
things and that led to the next phase of
my career where i just
started running around wearing uh like
kiss makeup and uh making fan films
which is a great phase of your career
great face right there i just like
dropping x and like
again this is
i i wouldn't say this is early youtube
but this is this is youtube like 2.0
yeah yeah so
um you know the mainstream uh the the
hollywood apparatus that that
dictates what what get
back then that what got made and what
didn't get made like that it
hadn't really caught on to the whole
youtube thing
it was still
niche
and so these fan films were getting a
ton of attention yeah like just a ton of
attention
which then
uh
eventually led to
the spot i'm in now where i'm creating
shows for netflix yeah um
and i guess the bridge between those two
two things was a show that i didn't
create
uh
but was intimately involved in both the
production with the creative and all
that was a show called castlevania on
yeah on netflix so that kind of ended up
being this like bridge which was great
because
now hindsight being an exact science or
really the only exact science i can look
back and go oh this makes sense like you
know i did some
uh i was part of some bigger things that
were very successful i rebelled against
everything and
uh produced these
had crazy ideas and then produced them
into these renegade bootleg fan films
and i called it the bootleg universe
and then
castlevania kind of showed that oh this
guy can also do the nerd thing and apply
it to the
system and and have it still work and
then that kind of opened the floodgates
and
yeah what if what if he didn't bootleg
it and it was just the thing right
the funniest thing was so i was on
production uh season one
of of castlevania
and uh i think it was after the sound
mix of episode four because season one
was like four more episodes it was after
the sound mix
uh a few of us
went out
for uh for for dinner to celebrate
there's like four of us we went out to
celebrate like i don't know
and i was still in my like [ __ ] the
system [ __ ] this you know i was like i
was like still in that that kind of
vibration
and um
i really wanted to do a hard r captain
planet um
you know where uh the planeteers are
are labeled eco-terrorists and
you know wheeler who's the the the guy
with the ring the fire ring is running
around like
burning
burning it just you know yeah i had this
whole whole
pitch that i was super in love with and
i'm like yeah i'm gonna do this as a fan
film
and then someone goes like what if you
just didn't do these as fan films dude
like why don't you go like talk to the
network like or or talk to the
the conglomerate that owns it like they
will talk to you you know
and i realize like oh
that's a good point like it just kind of
like
i keep bumping this i i hadn't quite
made that connection weirdly enough you
know because i i really enjoyed being
this
playing the character of this this this
rebel
you know i think this comes from just
watching way too much wrestling like
i was like casting myself in this in
this thing and not realizing like oh i
can just
call the guy that
develop shows or green lights here or or
whatever right yeah and get more get
more content up and going and and like
kind of turn this into an actual
business versus like
me running around just causing chaos
because
uh i
enjoy causing chaos i feel like i mean
it's also like being in your 20s like i
feel like there's like just a barrier
like if you're in your 20s you're not
allowed to call a conglomerate and they
won't talk to you it's like the moment
you're in your 30s you can call them up
like hey i have an idea and then like
okay let's talk it's like it's weird
like i feel like you also just crossed
this line of starting to get a little
bit older a little bit wiser and then
like they accept i was doing that in my
20s
yeah yeah because all the the the the
the producing executive producing
producing the big movies that was
happening in my 20s right so like
so i i i had the access in my 20s oh and
you're just like whatever i'm still
going to revel it anyways
[Laughter]
was it because like why were you were
you doing it without actually reaching
out to them because you just you didn't
want someone else to like control what
you could really do with it you want
like because i feel like there's a sense
like we all feel like we own these
characters a little bit right yeah like
i feel like i own luke skywalker a
little bit because
i have like the luke luke skywalker that
influenced my life and if i wanted to
make a story about luke skywalker i
don't want somebody else to tell me like
no you can't do that you know i want to
be able to tell my story with the
character
like was that a worry that you had like
that stopped you for sure
for sure it was that it was also you
know there was like a um
like a defeatist mentality i had to kind
of take on
to manifest this rebellion
you know yeah because i had to like um
method act in a way
in order to be like [ __ ] that we're
doing this and like
you know and and like i had people going
along with me mm-hmm so
so yeah it was like there was like a
it it's like i was sitting in this
vibration of needing to rebel
even though
i didn't necessarily need to rebel as
much as i
was rebelling yeah right and at a
certain point
um
it just became clear like
oh the next level of this
is integrating with the system
using the the the whatever cachet you
have
and work with the system
yeah which i guess is the arc of
kind of everyone who ultimately rebels
guys today's episode is brought to you
by storyblocks the one-stop shop for all
of your stock asset needs for creators
and businesses alike creators run into
this problem often you're working on a
video and you need something whether
it's b-roll audio images something to
tie your video together at quarter
digital we've scoured the internet for
stock assets throughout all the years
and the one thing that we found that was
consistent and better than all the rest
was storyblocks storyblocks offers high
quality 4k b-roll audio images
assets like motion graphics and after
effects templates and more
all in one convenient location with a
virtually unlimited library that's right
they're constantly updating their
library and they have an unlimited
all-access plan that allows you to
download
as much as you want from the site it's
all royalty free they know that making
videos is hard enough and they just want
it to make it easy for you to get what
you need so you can get the assets put
them in your video and move on to the
next part of the creative process that's
why we promote them so much here on the
podcast and generally on corridor
digital because we use them all the time
and if you guys are interested in
getting started for yourself or if
you're part of a team and you want to
get their enterprise plan for the whole
team go to
storyblocks.com to get started or just
click the link in the description below
and uh once again huge thanks to them
for sponsoring and um now let's get back
to the episode
[Laughter]
that's true like like tony hawk like now
he's you know what i mean like
he was a rebel
now he's like a business owner and like
kind of runs a conglomerate um yeah like
every rock star
like every rock every rock star
you know what i mean
yeah man they're out they're out like
like picketing napster like
it's an arc dude it's a cliche
i guess i'm i'm
on that
trajectory of that cliche yeah but yeah
aren't we all yeah and also to be fair
there was another piece to this whole
thing that that was
i guess
interesting to observe
uh i work now a lot with like
gaming ip mm-hmm right
uh and game companies
so to speak right so we're talking
it's public knowledge what i
what some of it it's some of it is not
public knowledge um
but you know we're talking like
ubisoft with
all their a lot of their titles uh
pub g like
there's there's
here's what i'm trying to say
um
movie studios are there there's like a
handful of conglomerates that ran
hollywood right we're talking like six
of them like disney universal sony fox
warner brothers warner brothers um and
then a couple mini majors and like
summit lionsgate
um obviously fox and disney have like
well disney acquired fox and there's
there's a consolidation happening now
but
um
the movie studios were really in the
business of leveraging their own
intellectual property
to uh make
make new content right so
um
so it ended up feeling like kind of a
claustrophobic experience
because there's like
this is what we make this is how we make
it and we're to use this as a
building block
to make that it's all very much like a
product very much a product right
because
filmed entertainment movies tv etc are
not
like a core business
vertical of of most gaming companies
there's a level of freedom that feels
like the west
and also game companies
and this is counter-intuitive
because you would think the movie
companies because they make so much
content they have such these such like
these deep reservoirs of ip that they
were they would
take more risks with it because they
have more of it and gaming companies
would be more like kind of closed off
and close to the best i found the
opposite to be true
game companies
tend to stretch more there's more brand
elasticity that they allow interesting
uh with their with their ip do you think
that's because the player is in control
of the main character so just naturally
elasticity in how you approach the game
no also let me just pull your mic to the
side a little bit because it's right in
front of your face there we go yeah
uh no i don't think that's why
i think it has to do with how the movie
industry evolved and how the gaming
industry gotcha right so the movie
industry
um
i'm gonna use the word cartel to
describe them i don't mean it in like a
facetious way but they they're
effectively a handful of people built
these studios they vertically integrated
the studios with the technology and
the means of production and the the the
like the sound stages and distribution
and then
kind of work together in tandem
to make sure that they maintain control
right so if there if if it was like the
in in the 1980s if you went and made a
movie independently the only shot you
had of people seeing it
was getting a major studio to distribute
it yeah so they could they had all the
leverage right all the power all the
distribution
um
and and and even like just making that
movie independently like you needed
their tools right you needed their
camera and their film and they're like
yeah if you didn't have it it like it
looked janky yeah
um so
because they had such a tight control
over the apparatus
the whole thing
they are not incentivized to innovate
right so they're so they're the
innovation happens incrementally
this is why james cameron's like a
revered figure in film because you like
the innovation happens from like a
handful of auteurs who force the
innovation
right they get power and then they
steamroll innovation and make it happen
right
and then
the the cartel industry would then go
and turn it into a gimmick and [ __ ]
erode wrote it that's just kind of how
it works and then terminator 3 and
terminal salvation terminator whatever
yeah
gaming on the flip side right is an
entire industry built off of the back of
innovation
yeah like if you're a game company and
you have a hit game
and then you don't innovate
that game company is [ __ ]
it is it is just game over
right it's it's it like
because gaming you know like like uh uh
uh tech gets a lot of credit for for
this but i would argue that
gaming has been innovating on parallel
on a parallel path to tech right like um
handheld devices like the game boy
were
like [ __ ]
yeah he interviewed was there before
your iphone right right yeah so um you
know nintendo like they they took crazy
[ __ ] swings like the power glove the
virtual boy these are crazy [ __ ]
swings this is like
they're a tech company
right gaming companies are tech
companies whether whether they're doing
hardware whether they're doing software
or in the case of nintendo both
and their ip companies yeah right so
they're forced to innovate because if
you don't innovate you're [ __ ]
and um
and this is again it's
innovate with the hardware innovate with
the software innovate with gameplay
mechanics it's it's it's built off of
the back of innovation yeah
and you're literally getting a new
system a hardware system like every four
to five years like imagine if you're in
the movies like all right now we're
doing 36 millimeter now we're doing 40
millimeter film now we're doing 55
millimeter film it's like that if that
was happening every four years in the
movie industry since like 1930 that
affects the culture of the organization
100 it just does right so
uh
movie movie people movie the movie
apparatus historically has been very
risk-averse
because it's like don't rock the boat
don't don't piss anyone off
don't don't get blackballed
right tech is the opposite piss everyone
off break some [ __ ]
cause anarchy
yeah
yeah just get people get eyeballs on
your system and you know start making a
product that's the tech industry yeah
you know it's funny when you talk about
like not rocking about two with like the
entertainment industry like there's this
this element that like doesn't get
talked about too much which is like
that question of like will this work
again like
what makes people want to see your movie
and everybody feels like they have the
answer but deep down no one has the
answer it's like sometimes that new
thing just comes out and it's amazing
and sometimes that thing comes out
that's great but no one sees it and
she's like everybody's trying to figure
out the imperfect science around like
okay people love batman so if we put
batman in it and we keep it gritty we
should at least sell this many tickets
based on past experiment experience but
we're still just guessing you know yeah
and that's corporate that's corporate
america at play yeah
trying to quantize what makes
entertainment
valuable versus
it's trying to sell a future that's
uncertain
with a degree of certainty right you're
trying to you're trying to bake
certainty into an uncertain future
in order to
affect the stock price
right
but again
um
and i might get some flack for saying
this but like
there are a few examples like how much
innovation actually happens in madden so
let's you can find outliers in what i'm
saying but for the most part if call of
duty just straight up stops innovating
they become medal of honor tomorrow
right
suck it middle of honor fans
dude i love medal of honor man like i'm
all about catching those grenades and
throwing them back yep right innovated
that mechanic like from from yeah
recollection like metal bonner was the
i love that the innovator of that
mechanic um
but yeah um
so
so i'm curious like
you know i'm very much on like this
other side of the industry that's just
battling its way out from like you know
the digital age which is not at all
associated with like these big studios
and you know everything all the success
we have just comes from like the direct
relationship with the audience yes um so
i really don't have much experience
trying to make projects happen
in quote unquote in the system right
what is that what is it like trying to
get a project off the ground these days
in the traditional media system like how
what does the process go like
step one through step there isn't 100
that's the thing because
it's completely unique you know i've i
don't know how many projects i've been a
part of at this point
yeah like i i don't know so i don't want
to just throw a number out
um
i could
it doesn't matter there's there's a lot
um everything every single time it came
together differently huh so like so like
let's say right now you're like all
right i want to make
an action film about two guys there are
great shots one's a cop one's a farmer
and is it a movie or is it serious a
movie okay who's directing it
this is all this is what you have this
is your starting point so now the next
thing you have to figure out is like
who's your director or like
like i'm just saying like so addie
shankar is right here he's like all
right i'm deciding i'm gonna make a
movie
what's the next step
are you asking addie shankar right now
or is that just another filmmaker out
there trying to get their movie major
eddie shankar right now you right now if
you like if you suddenly you walked out
of this room
with a passion in your heart a burning
passion to make a film
what would be your next steps how would
you try to get it off the ground i mean
i'd call
a handful of
buyers and just tell them hey this is
what i'm looking to do next
okay yeah so when you say buyers like
what do you mean by that like like
netflix hbo that kind of thing and what
what makes them say yes
track record i guess yeah yeah
what if you didn't have a track record
yeah that's that's the more interesting
question right because i i don't think
like me i'm like particularly helpful to
anybody right because then it's just
like oh yes well
you know you just pick up the phone and
you get in it it's not really not
helpful like it just
look i remember i'm being on the other
side of this
moving out to la not knowing anybody
trying to figure out how the [ __ ] this
industry worked
and listening to interviews from
douchebag filmmakers such as myself
right now
and they would say things like yes
making a movie is like creme brulee you
need to and you're like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about like give me
practical [ __ ] steps right
so
so your question is
if you're a
young filmmaker today sure yeah young
filmmaker how do you get your
foot in the door yeah how do you how do
you how do you try to make a movie okay
with one of these systems
the best way to do it is not try to make
your movie
so you gotta really like try to focus on
what they're trying to deliver as a
product yes and and work with that
right
there's uh open writing
assignments all the time there's open
directing assignments all the time right
get in the room get in contention for
one of those
makes sense because this this passion
project uh two guys in the farmer yeah
movie
like
they might already have something like
that you know what i mean how do you
know that this like you just don't know
figure out what your
superpower is because everyone has one
right and it's it's really figuring out
like what that super power is and what
your superpowers are not
you know like i meet a lot of young
filmmakers who who are like have like
the dopest visuals
and they have no sense of story
and if you if you go in knowing that
that's great you can work around that
right yeah you can work around that
weakness
if you lack the self-awareness and think
you're like this master storyteller
yeah you're gonna strike out
and then you end up wondering why you're
getting so many notes and he gets all
you got frustrated you get frustrated
and you're like oh they're not
interested in my vid it's like it's a
whole thing so
the best way to get in is work through a
system i'll give you another example of
this right if you want to break into
youtube today
doing what you do
right which is like vfx
stunts
action shorts and tutorials that's
that's what corridor is
and a podcast so it's it's that right
it's like basically like a
like a like a film school without the
like the weird know-it-all professors
right yes well there's at least one
weird knowledge professor right
[Laughter]
how do you
break into that well the best way to do
that is to get your attention or the
attention of someone at corridor
and find a role within corridor
not to go try to build your own corridor
yeah
yeah because you're it's a huge uphill
battle it's a huge upper battle and and
there and there are
there's there's like a
well of mistakes that you've made
that you're aware that you made that you
won't make again
that you can save someone the legwork
you know yeah
it's funny like looking at corridor like
there have been people that come into
the company and then move on from the
company
you know like it's clint did that clint
yeah great example great example he grew
immensely as just a human being
while here right i saw this dude who was
kind of like
seemed a little stressed out and he
works with you and then boom stress is
gone he's just creating
yeah and then also like
i think community is huge with with any
creative endeavor like like authentic
community not the
hey we're gonna meet up and complain
about [ __ ] and be negative and think
that we know better and the batman movie
should have been made like this and
instead they all suck like not not that
community that's just toxicity
but i mean
actually like we're going to get
together and
build that like that
that tribe
i think that's
i personally underestimated how
important that was in my own journey
that was the thing that
people always talked about with college
it's like you know you go to school for
film you're probably not going to really
learn
how to make a good movie right they're
going to teach you how to be a good crew
member for equipment that's out of data
some 15 years ago you know yeah but what
you will meet is
10 5 20 you know a chunk of people
that are just as passionate about doing
what you're doing sure and then together
you guys can team up and start making
some cool for sure
so if you're trying to break into the
industry
get staffed on something even if it's
like a super low level spot on that
thing because then you can like move up
the ecosystem you can move up the ladder
you can get more experience and more
importantly you can learn from people
who are doing it at a high level right
or a higher level
and
one day
hopefully you may have the leverage
you may accrue and amass the leverage to
be able to
get your own project through the system
right but at that point you will have to
have so much like knowledge and
wherewithal
that
it will be a different project than the
one you'd pitch as a
yeah as a as a novice that's very true
we tried to get uh
we had this you know this series idea
called tether yes or movie idea
and then it became the beast
and then we wrote a script for the beast
and we started shopping it around
and the most serious i guess opportunity
we had i got our approaches like hey
this is cool i like the idea i like the
setting
here's a structure for how we do our
horror films if you guys can rewrite it
to match the structure then we can fund
you and i think it's a perfect example
it's like it's not your passion project
you need to go in and fit somebody
else's product that they're trying to
deliver and help them deliver what they
want to deliver
and then from there you know you meet
people you talk to people and you can
refine it from there
but that's very much a realization of
like well
we don't want to make a generic horror
movie it hits these beats and we just
reskin it to like look like our thing
like we want to make this and that's
kind of a realization that like the only
way we will get to make this is when we
have enough audience support
and resources to just make it for sure
you know you won't be able to talk to
anybody else and get the permission to
do it or anything like that yeah
yeah
yeah and
you know look if you want to do the
auteur thing
then they got to kind of follow your
path
build the audience organically right
yeah
uh
be able to demonstrate that you have an
audience waiting for your crazy idea or
not so crazy idea just just just for
your
unconventional concept
right and then it just becomes a quite
like an economics question like
can we like how much can we make it for
where we retain the
the vision and and don't have to start
opening it up to get a bigger audience
yeah what's that finding that balance
and that's that's a really hard question
i think a lot of people have to like ask
themselves which is like
if you don't have an audience now yeah
why would you have an audience just
because your thing gets funded
you know if what you're making now isn't
speaking to people or isn't finding a
voice or finding people that are
passionate about it
more money isn't going to sell me yeah
there's there's um there's also this
other
kind of disarming reality of
i don't want to say the movie business
the content business
there's a lot of [ __ ] that gets paid for
made completed and never [ __ ]
released yeah
because the
the hardest part of the equation
is getting distribution
still still
because look if you make a movie for two
million dollars
yeah you can dump it on youtube
but like you're gonna have a bunch of
pissed off investors you know yeah yeah
because you're not making any of your
money back right
so where could you go with a movie for
two million dollars well it's all that
you know you've got you've got like uh
like netflix is like no we're good
there's there's international so
there's a few
markets you should go to like uh like
can has one um
afm the american film market that's
around like october november in santa
monica
and there are these film markets
that you can go to
and you show up there with your film and
then you sell it individually
to uh international distributors right
and you do that with the help of a sales
agent
who goes there with you and tries to get
you okay we're gonna sell france said oh
we sold france for
fifty thousand dollars cool right
and you piecemeal distribution contracts
that way
and that works for small movies and huge
movies
because um there's a need for product
but again
they're it's it's the example you gave
about the horror film
they're not looking for you to like
get your vision out there they need a
specific thing for their audience right
right they know that hey we have a slot
for a horror movie
yeah it's gotta be a horror movie it's
gotta be a horror movie and do you have
a horror movie cool we can talk right
and then you find out like oh it's a
ghost movie no what we found is we ghost
movies don't work well in our territory
home invasion horror movies work well so
we're looking for a home invasion horror
movie and it gets it gets like really
specific because again this industry is
old
right so
so um
so as much as it seems kind of like
random and
um and and some of the things the
outliers the hits are they're just
they're just random and they just kind
of blow up but most of it
most of the movie business has a margin
business mm-hmm and
and like you can't take risks in a
margin business because you know hey
it's gonna [ __ ] bomb
right like
like
yeah like uh
we have a slot to release an action
thriller if we don't release that action
thriller
and instead we release this
dramedy about your life as a
screenwriter
our company goes under right
or if we
release this action thriller
that um we know hey if we have dolph
lundgren in it or mickey rourke in it
and ideally both of them in it
and another mma fighter we know it'll
sell x number of units
but instead we don't cast them and we
cast like you and your boy
yeah then it's like it goes away and
then you realize like oh [ __ ]
this is an old business so it's all been
kind of crystallized into
um
into these like models
and do you think there's truth to things
like that or is it superstition when
somebody's like oh if you have dolph
lundgren in it it'll sell this many
times absolutely truth to this so if you
go to like uh what's the uh not box
office mojo i think that's like a
website right
and you google like
um
jason statham or not google you write
his name right jason statham look
through all the jason statham action
movies and you'll see
like oh [ __ ] there's actually like a
trajectory to these things
holy [ __ ] like they're they they make a
rout around the same amount of money and
then all of a sudden theatrically
and then
and then that number like kind of starts
going down and down and down oh and then
he's in the fast and furious now that
number starts going up and up and up and
up there
it's not an exact science
but it's not superstition either
yeah and look this is a sector of the
business but this is most of the
business
yeah most of it operates by that right
so like
i was like kind of laughing like not not
in like a in a haha
mean way like i was watching an old
podcast because i again love you guys
and i love clint
and then you had freddy wong on there
and he was like
talking about how like oh man my life
would be so different if i just focused
on making low-budget horror movies and
i'd be like a working filmmaker today
like making content like pretty
regularly and i've worked up my way up
the ladder but instead i'm like this
youtube guy
without a youtube channel
i'm like
i [ __ ] told you guys that like
like 10 years ago that's exactly the
advice i gave you guys i said okay look
focus on low budget horror movies
and then start adding more action into
them
and then pivot into like low budget or
low budget action thrillers mm-hmm
yeah
and go from there and then go from there
i and you know it's funny like that path
that doorway open like multiple times
yes and we'd put like a foot on the path
and back oh we'd like to take our foot
back
i i think
it yeah
well it's not the path for you right i
mean this what we're doing now it's not
the path for you
because and i can get into why but i
don't again i i i feel like a douche bag
i'm just kind of like
it is i like having you break down like
what's going on here's why it's not the
past it's a podcast just for me now
here's why that's not was not the path
for you okay
uh
you're like a tribe leader
i your your path i always felt was to
build and grow an ecosystem
and
and grow a collective right like the
thing you every time we would meet you'd
say yes you know like we don't spend
more than we make
i think they give you a really refined
accent yeah well you were [ __ ]
refined in my mind you were look at your
hair bro
like you look like a character out of
castlevania you look like a belmont hell
yeah you know what i mean i could
totally see you being a belmont
um
and belmonts are aristocrats um
yeah so that was like that never
necessarily needed to be your path and
the thing is if you're going and making
a
a low-budget film for a distributor
like
you kind of have to be exclusive and you
kind of have to exclusively do that and
then hand it over and then you're done
right so the whole corridor thing kind
of
starts fizzling yeah
yeah 100 yeah
man interesting stuff
i'm glad that we ended up where we we
did and that we made the decisions we
did along the way like being able to put
my foot into those worlds a little bit
it was like super enlightening and like
taught me a bunch
um and i would never give up those
experiences but it also just helped
reinforce that like we're on the right
path right now oh for sure for myself
you know for sure dude you're crushing
it thanks man you're crushing it
everybody here's crushing it you're
crushing it too
appreciate it yeah you are
you're kind of you're doing a lot of
things that i'm like like i kind of wish
i was doing that too
you know
like you're getting to play with the ips
in a way that i've always kind of wanted
to play with them as well which actually
okay
what's
what's your favorite slash what's the
best video game movie that's been made
or a tv show in your opinion
and what do you think is the
like untapped game currently that would
make for a really good tv series or
movie so i'm gonna be like that annoying
guest
and say that like
i don't have opinions about
content i don't believe that anything's
like the best or the worst or any i just
like i don't have opinions
um
and i've trained my mind to not have
opinions
because i've realized like
that some of that's ego
because then it's like
my perspective based on my
the kaleidoscope of sounds and images
that make my life and then i'm
judging this
piece of art and like well you know what
they could have really improved is in
the third act
right so you kind of have to just cut
the cord with that because i don't
control it so now
if i'm not involved
in the production of it i just try to
look at it as like moment to moment at
moment to moment like how is this making
me feel
and it's not making me feel good there
any fine i'll turn it off because i like
wasn't feeling didn't make me feel good
yeah and that's
that's it the moment i start getting
into like the ranking of it all
it's not like full negativity but it
feels like a branch off of the tree of
negativity interesting where you're like
judging things
based off of
an arbitrary
set of things that actually don't exist
you know yeah it's like i guess why why
go through life having to make things
good and bad for yourself it's just like
you know you like it do more of it and
leave it at that
yeah
like i had an amazing time watching this
movie called night at the roxbury
yeah the one with uh what said not will
ferrell and uh
yeah
love that movie
right
but i'm just like enjoying the process
of watching this i'm not trying to
analyze like the like the shots and the
deconstruction and then you know so it
yeah and it's been
yeah
okay let me focus on what i can control
does that make sense yeah like and i
just focus on what i can control if i
can't control it
then i don't because i look at it as
like every word every thought is just my
life force
and if i'm dumping life force
into something that i do not control
and trying to control it with a
narrative
i'm
i'm wasting my energy
man where's the wisdom right there
yeah yeah cool
that's a good thing to think
about seriously
man
well
i'm gonna hit you with this next
question anyways
if you had to make a metal gear solid
movie yeah how would you approach it
have you thought about it at all oh yeah
are you a solid fan oh yeah okay what
would your metal gear solve movie look
like
we actually get it like how deep do you
want to get into this hit me
you know like
i guess the the
the broad strokes of it
this is just the broad strokes and if
you'd like to dissect deeper i'm i'm i'm
down if you want to switch to the next
question i'm down also
i wouldn't make it gritty
right metal gear solid is not the dark
knight yeah definitely
and the more you try to make it the dark
knight
the more it like loses what's special
about it right this is a dude who
[ __ ] carries you on a cardboard box
to hide in
you know what i mean
yeah there's a
there's a there's a i don't want to say
wackiness because again wackiness it
sounds like judgment but
well there's a wackiness there's a
wackiness yeah it's like a negative
wackiness not a negative wackiness yeah
but there's a there's a there's a
wackiness and a self-awareness
that it that it has not deadpool's
self-awareness right he's not but but
like
you know like when i look back at the
first metal gear or not that's not the
first metal gear sorry metal gear solid
right so the first playstation one metal
gear
like
what were some of the most memorable
moments right and it's like oh [ __ ] the
psycho mantis
moment yeah
you know yeah um
so super wacky
like it's super intense and cool but
it's also really fun it's cool right so
it's really just kind of
um
not not making it overly gritty not
making it overly
like the dark knight
but look again i don't think there's a
right way or wrong way to do it i think
that's just that's just how i would
approach it um
that's how i see the that's how i how i
see it i
throw throw this to like 50 different
people and you'll get 50 different
responses i don't think one's the right
way one's the wrong way i don't think
there's a right way or wrong way to do
anything yeah um
yeah
so
so let's say you're making a movie your
way you kind of describe the tone here
what story would you pick
or combination thereof
sliver thereof but i feel like you know
this is where
um and this is unique to me because i'm
i'm also a writer you know like a
someone who can direct and write
because these are now like skills i've
acquired through the
[ __ ] 14 years i've been doing this
um
i would just
write an original story completely a
completely original story
why would you do that that way just so
you can like
like
is that where your inspiration comes
from when like you can just delve into
like something with no
predetermined like construct and you
just go for it uh ju i i don't know just
for metal gear that's that's
that's just how i would
that that's that's what i would want to
do and like then i would kind of ask the
question like okay is this appropriate
for the fan base am i delivering because
also when you're like working with
with with big brands like that and
you're working with um you know that
would be like a big big budget film
because there isn't really a
low budget version of
right of of of metal gear
then i would ask the hard questions of
myself like okay is this approach
delivering the experience
for
the pre-existing fan base
and
is it uh
opening the door to converting people
who are potential fans into fans right
and and
and if the answer is no then i that i'm
just not the right guy to
i'm just not the right guy to do that
yeah right and i think like
again metal gear's such a specific one
um
yeah metal gears are such a such a
specific one
and
to be fair i don't look at myself as the
right
person to do that or the right person to
do anything right
i just kind of things come to me and
um
and i'm just grateful that opportunities
come to me
and
only want to proceed if they're in 100
alignment
with the people involved and the
audience
you know that's probably a really good
way to make sure you don't end up doing
something that later on just crumbles
and turns into a big stress ball
and making sure that the yeah
everything's set correctly for sure
and and like
and not make a decision out of ego
right because
if if you're working with a with a with
a beloved property like metal gear and i
think metal gear is also a interesting
one because then there's also the kojima
element right it's not
yeah i mean it's not it's a very
hypothetical argument because kojima
would obviously like be like this is
like i'm gonna make metal gear in the
movie you know sure but
the the other way of just i guess just
removing it from the metal gear of it
all right and not in that specific
instance it's like working with an
author
on a book right it's like it's like
adapting harry potter yeah there's an
auteur who had a vision there right so
you're so you've kind of got two paths
here you can either
uh
be their
executor
right
like go to jk rowling and say okay what
are you we're gonna we're gonna
translate
the sorcerer's stone
into
a movie
or
go in and just like literally do your
own you know frank miller dark knight
returns it right and do your own do your
do your own
your own thing write your you know uh uh
uh
paint your own graffiti it or stamp your
own stamp on it right
now if the situation doesn't call for
that
and you try to push it that way that's
just ego
right but there are a lot of situations
that do actively call for that
right where like
they're like look we need your take on
i don't [ __ ] know
gi joe
right because we did like all these
things and they didn't quite
land the way we wanted them to land so
we need like a uh like a like a fresh
take
right
yeah i feel like the challenge with all
its stuff especially like when working
with an ip that's
well especially when working with like a
game ip like if you wanted to translate
malaga solid or really any like halo or
any like crazy beloved video game thing
to the screen
is like the ideal world is where you
you capture what made it good so that
everybody or you capture what made it i
guess inspiring so that everybody that
like got into that ip
can enjoy what you make but then ideally
you also capture
whatever it was in there
that made you love it in the first place
so that people who are seeing it for the
first time feel that same spark
you know like if you can capture the
thing that like made you go like dang
metal gear solid is a great game you can
capture that and bring that into your
movie or your tv show for people who
haven't played metal gear so i'll be
like wow this is really cool metal gear
solid is a really cool world or snake is
a really cool character like that's
where
like things really succeed but it's hard
to really do that to be able to like
double capture that the genius that
worked once then like bring it to life
again
sure
and it's also tricky
it adds an additional layer of
trickiness when that game
uses so much of the language of cinema
yeah
to achieve that effect right yeah it's
like making a grand theft auto movie
yeah it's like there's already a huge
movie in grand theft auto already um
because i would argue in a lot of ways
grand theft auto is like an engine there
actually is a grand theft auto movie did
you know that
i didn't know that yeah
so uh this is this is a crazy story so
uh i believe in the 70s
ron howard
wrote directed and starred in a grand
theft auto movie produced by roger
corman yeah really yeah so roger corman
who's uh and
he's he was like a legendary
bc movie
financier producer he had like a like
his own studio where you just churn out
these like
uh genre movies back in the day and a
lot of
household name filmmakers like ron
howard james cameron like a lot of these
guys got their start
working for roger corman so he's like a
you know revered
revered figure
uh of sorts
in in in in the business kind of much
obviously much much older um but yeah he
made this movie called grand theft auto
uh
starring written directed by
ron howard and it feels very much like
grand theft auto
so
so so roger corman ran around
selling the rights to grand theft auto
and fox
um
optioned it like in the 2000s
and started developing grand theft auto
for eminem huh
um i can't remember who wrote the script
this was just blanking on me but this
was like a script that people liked
um
and i anyways the rights lapsed fox just
didn't get involved and then i found out
about this
so i tried to get the rides from roger
corbin right
and then you know so this is like [ __ ]
2008 2009 i'd literally been in la for
months and i heard about this i'm like
you know how i work right i'm just kind
of like i become like a target i'm like
wait what grand theft auto is available
uh where how
to call who would have to call so i get
a meeting with roger corman
i'm trying to like figure this out
and and i don't have no idea what the
[ __ ] i'm doing right so i'm i'm winging
it but you know when you're winging it
you have more bravado than when you know
oh 100 right yeah because you don't want
them to know that you're winging it you
don't know that you're winging it you
know what i mean like yeah you're like
you're like behaving like a character
from a [ __ ] movie which is like what
i did from most of my 20s i was just
behaving like a character i was like oh
fast and furious okay i would behave
like that guy it's all about family
um
so so yeah like uh and then
i like
through four degrees of separation
there are these two brothers i believe
i remember christmas who who like kind
of created grand theft auto
like in the game the game yeah i don't
know if they're brothers but yeah
there's two basically two dudes like sam
something and yeah yeah like dan
something yeah
and so
uh i knew through again four degrees of
separation i get in touch with one of
the dude's neighbor wow yeah i'm like
23.
complete delusion here right
um
so
uh i i tell this guy hey uh can you just
stop this guy and like hand him a note
i'll like email you
another hand in the note right
and
and um
and i knew that like i couldn't be like
hi sir i would like really like to make
a grand theft auto movie please please
please it was my request was
i'm making a grand theft auto movie and
i'm getting the rights you know what i
mean like that
that whole thing and uh
yeah then i heard back from like
rockstar legal and we like went back and
forth for a while and they were like hi
uh you're a friend of the court do not
go down this road
uh our grand theft auto game rights have
eclipsed any movie right so like
literally if you're going to make a
grand theft auto movie it has to be like
a strict remake of
that movie that ron howard uh directed
and started wow
and i'm like
kind of weighing my options
[Music]
i'm like well why don't we just work
together and i'll make the grand theft
auto movie for you for rockstar i mean
i'm just trying that um
also the week i moved to la i just uh
got in touch with nintendo like nintendo
america
and i just
was like
oh my god i was [ __ ] insane dude i
like
like get in touch with them and i write
this whole thing uh and i i
was like
again this was a while ago but
i i basically started talking to like
high up executives in nintendo
and i was like look
i will
make
it has to be a two picture deal i can't
just commit you know to one movie with
you guys it has to be two
just that's right out of the gate with
nintendo yeah it was like yeah
i didn't even how do you even get in
touch with nintendo as a 23 year old you
just find their number and you call them
and you leave a message
that's it yeah people call you back dude
this is like
like getting in touch with steven
spielberg that's [ __ ] hard right dude
has gatekeepers and this and there's
like people trying to get in touch with
them most corporate entities like there
are people there to answer the phones
they'll call you back
i'll [ __ ] call you back someone will
have a conversation with you somewhere
um
yeah and i just realized like oh you can
just call people up and their
information is somewhere on the internet
right and i figured out how to get their
information and i'll just call them up
and start having conversations
huh like i i flew to atlanta on a red
eye and went like deep deep deep into
the [ __ ] um
uh like kind of like the farming area to
meet with the uh oh what's his name
xavier
xavier or something you like created the
cabbage patch kids
wanted to make a hard heart cabbage
patch kids
yeah and like you know
um
so the rockstar thing
grand theft auto never happened huh no
no of course not
i mean i know the answer at all we would
all know about this
uh but
but i guess i don't know why we got into
that but i or how this story how we lean
it on this story but the point is
i realized when i first moved out here
that
people were like a degree of separation
and also video games weren't looked at
as this like
triple a premium ip right they were like
giving the [ __ ] to you a bull yeah
yeah right some of the biggest games
ever
have adaptations by you a bull yeah you
know what i mean
yeah like so
like was there like some sort of text
thing going on with him like how did he
continue to make all these games or
videos that were just not sure movies
that were like
that is what it is right like um you
know direct-to-video low-budget films
get made all the time that again these
are they're they just got the rights and
made them it's what we're talking about
about this the
distribution slots yeah right
what to me was was
shocking
was that the game companies were
allowing this to happen
with their intellectual property yeah
right
yeah just over and over i mean uh what
did he do he did obviously far cry far
cry house of the dead house the dead
blood rain
uh
uh alone in the dark afraid of the dark
something like that yeah um
postal
there's a fantasy one that has jason
statham in it i can't remember yeah it's
like under siege or dragon yeah yeah
yeah and probably like one or two more
that i can't remember that's crazy so
yeah like you know it was like
getting in touch
with
rights holders i mean i though the week
i moved
before i even moved to la my strategy
was i made an excel spreadsheet
and i had every single piece of
intellectual property that i loved
growing up on it
and then i tried to figure out who owned
it
and i just called him like hey this is
available
huh and someone would [ __ ] hit you
back and be like no [ __ ] you
or uh yes let's talk you know yeah and
then
they would talk a little bit and we're
like you're a child call me call me in
20 years
[Laughter]
you know um but but yeah no i like
it was it was
a huge education experience and i also
like would get like hyper close you know
like um
to things like
and by the way i wasn't
focused on the kind of content that i do
now which is my passion like i'm
passionate about the stuff i do now
i was looking at everything like i was
like why is there no hard r captain
crunch movie right like
where's like the horror movie with tony
the tiger like you know
um
uh you know i looked at like like
voltron like uh had a conversation about
paddington bear like
because i grew up uh in hong kong which
was a british colony so i was very
familiar with like the
uh the british ip the the the british ib
right yeah um
though the one that i was like
the one i got like closest on
and i don't remember fully why this
didn't materialize
but it was something to do with me and
again this was early in my career right
like later on
i got
access to different stuff and whatnot
but uh i loved indian in the cupboard um
i wanted to like do anything in the
cupboard so i like got in touch with the
author and
went down the road on that
they did end up making a movie for that
too they did yeah yeah they made one
movie but they were like five books
right
yeah it's a good movie yeah
yeah darth vader's in it yes
[Laughter]
yeah
um
you wanna talk about uh guardians of
justice settle sure
so
i'll i'll intro and even though you're
going to probably do much better job in
showing it but you've been working on
this project for years and years and
years and it's funny because like
we shot a scene for you
way back in the day yeah and
it's funny like there's so much time
elapsed that when it came out people
like did you know this movie is using
some of your stuff it's like yeah we
know
it's like so many people reached out to
us like thinking that you guys had just
ripped us off i mean i did rip you off
but
in a consensual way in a consensual way
it was exciting um
no i remember being like hey nico i i
i want you to do this thing and only you
can do it
so can you please do it and you're like
yeah sure
and i'm like oh thank you
that was great seven years later and
seven years later i came out or actually
it was probably like five and a half
years after you shot the thing maybe
yeah and now i have a little netflix
credit or imdb credit yeah
which is right netflix filmmaker hello
yeah
boom i always make do i always make good
on my promises that's what i said i said
yeah yeah so
when you first started that project and
like along the way you know a lot of
what you were talking about i was like
it was an extension of your bootleg
universe but also a way for you to
take a lot of these ideas and characters
you know that were close to you in like
ways you wanted to twist them a little
bit
and you're just like well let's just not
call him superman let's just not call
him batman but we get it it's basically
that archetype
and
and so you got to finally kind of jump
into these characters and make your own
story in your own world around this
but you know it obviously took five or
six years to do yes so i'm a little
curious like what was the journey like
why did it take so long and like what
did you learn about that process and
kind of your love for the characters and
this that medium along the way
so there's also i mean so
guardians of justice opens with a
suicide
right which is a great story opening in
my opinion yeah it's like basically
superman is depressed
you know he talks about how
he's got super hearing so he hears the
whole world screaming for help all the
time yeah if he goes to sleep and he
wakes up someone's died and he feels
guilt because he could have done
something about it right
and
then he takes it loads of kryptonite
pull it into a gun and he shoots himself
in the head on live tv
that's how it opens such a good opening
appreciate it um
without getting into that i mean we can
get into it if you'd like but
like there's a huge personal element to
the story
in and of itself right
so
that in and of itself when you make
something that's personal
yeah there's you know superman and
batman the flash wonder woman all that
there's that but also ultimately the
story was personal when you make
something that personal
it takes an emotional toll on you
that is hard to explain you know
it's hard to it's just hard to explain
it yeah it feels almost like giving
birth i i've never given birth so i
shouldn't [ __ ] say that
like
or like father you know like fatherhood
or something like that like i don't have
any children but like yeah you're
pouring your you're pouring yourself
into it and of course the vessel you're
pouring yourself into does not not
always reflect
what you're pouring into it necessarily
and then and then like you got to fight
certain impulses that you don't that
that you're not aware that you have to
fight like uh perfectionism
uh you know being a control freak
on a parallel path right
uh the way the story's told through 16
different mediums
live action 2d animation 3d animation
stop motion claymation like [ __ ] just
every you know like
south park paper animation
first person pov you know what i mean
like just
it's hard to explain
the show unless you watch it right would
you is that fair to say yeah
imagine trying to explain the show when
the show doesn't exist right
and you kind of learned the show along
the way too i didn't have i realized how
bad of a communicator i used to be i
didn't know
because i just thought like
i was this amazing communicator right
then you get into it and you're like oh
my god i'm just like not [ __ ]
specific at all in how i speak like like
my words are like kind of like i'm like
kind of like a brat and the way i use my
get [ __ ] specific man when you say
hair what do you mean how short how what
um
and and it forced me to become someone
who could finish the show does that make
sense i didn't start that project
take the vision aside take the personal
aspect aside take superman and batman
take all that aside i did not start that
project
as
the person that could finish that
project i had to become the person who
could amass the tools and the emotional
maturity to finish that project
yeah
so looking at it now
how do you feel about it
like do you feel like it's this do you
think it was this thing that represents
kind of your growth and step into like
the new era of
of who you are now
don't really think about it yeah i don't
really think about it
you know because ultimately
um
i realized that
there's there's there's a version of
life where you're kind of
having these expectations and they may
come in the forms of hopes and dreams
they may feel positive
but the universe is going to deliver
something for you in an unexpected way
and it's about being prepared for the
unexpected it's about stepping into the
unknown without fear
and
i let go of any sense of like attachment
ownership
uh expectation
and
that
process
somehow emotionally cut the cord about
of like feeling anything it's more of an
experience
it's like i experienced this thing
that is out in the ether that some
people respond to very passionately
because they [ __ ] love it right
they're like nothing like this
exists i [ __ ] love it
when making something like that don't
you still have to kind of judge if it's
working or not if it's good or bad so
you can like get it to the point where
it's working yes
so how do you do that while also still
kind of cutting that chord
um
that's a great question
you know i i've
well and i've i've learned this from
producing
and working with
very hyper talented individuals that
should be [ __ ] james cameron
household names who just sabotage
right and
um
and just kind of observing
what the thing that what is the unifying
thing
that
leads to that kind of self-sabotage and
it's 100 times ego
and it's ego so deep that there's a lack
of awareness that it's even ego how do
you think how do you define ego
just uh just so we're on the same
i don't know i don't know how to define
ego i mean i can i can observe it right
because there's like there's like the
soul
there's like the soul there's the alien
piloting the the
the exoskeleton
right
and then there's the this being that
thinks that it is the kaleidoscope of
sounds and images
and is building stories around
everything that's the ego
okay right look storytelling's great
but where are we right now
america [ __ ] america doesn't exist
these are these are these are constructs
right and they're constructs
that are are are made up and like passed
down right this is microphone's a made
up word
right
yeah and like
it it's like
if you get too attached to the story you
get too attached to the construct
then you're in the ego
uh how i see it and you're in the ego
and then you're driven by the ego pardon
and that's where the self-sabotage
starts because the ego wants to preserve
itself preserve its identity so then
you're out being like
you know
and then then you lose
and and here's where it [ __ ] you
you lose
sight that you are the architect of
your reality you are the architect of
your life everything that you have has
has been
constructed around you are a series of
decisions that you're making that's
manifesting them
these these things right yeah and
there's a version where they where life
is happening for you
and then there's a version where life is
happening against you
right
so there's these are like different
realities you can step into
um and
when i meet people who
and this has nothing to do with talent
dude it has nothing to do with talent
when people like identify too much with
their avatar
and they're like i'm from this place and
from this socio-economic thing i do then
this and this and then then you're like
you're effectively stuck in that
yeah yeah that makes sense does that
make sense or did i go like like i i
don't know okay that means it's good
it's good
you gotta get a little bit of that woo
for you to even like you know you gotta
land the plane somewhere but first you
gotta get in the air to land the plane
so uh so yeah like when i've when i've
observed like ego at play
it just [ __ ] sabotages every single
time
and
when you can kind of
start peeling
away the layers of the ego because it's
not just a binary thing there's like
layers to this right
and there are things that like trigger
people right like um if you were
you know
bullied you know when you were young or
something and then like
you you can you come face to face with
the high school bully like or the middle
school or whatever like that or maybe it
was like a like a parent that mistreated
you
your your body wants to like flip into
revenge right that's kind of the
paradoxical nature of
life
right like if you feel unloved or
mistreated your natural it's natural
like like the the human mind wants to
snap into revenge to get to like yeah
get even it's like if somebody's mean to
you you're mean to them right
but the paradox is if you do that you're
also poisoning yourself yeah right if
you pick the path of revenge you're
[ __ ] poisoning yourself that's the
paradox so it's like
cutting the cord with it letting it go
realizing that that has nothing to do
with you it has everything to do with
them
easier said than done right but easier
said than done right so the more you can
kind of cut the cord with that [ __ ]
those are the programs that are running
around in your mind effectively like
controlling you because then you're
being you're being led and driven by
trauma right so
again if you're a
like again so many talented people i
know like like much older than me right
degenerate because again i when i was
young i was working with much older
people like
i'm like dude
you're trying to prove something to
someone else you're trying to prove
something to yourself
how about existing in a vibration of not
having to prove how about you do this
because you love it
it'll it'll spark a different
thing
it'll the art will come out a little
differently you'll enter a reality of
ease
yeah we always talk about like when
you're farming something
if you can enjoy it it shows on camera
right art doesn't have to be pain right
right there they're all these like
things that people latch onto sometimes
so
you know um
yeah the more you cut the cord with ego
then the more you're just looking at
things objectively
and um i think for me
personally on guardians of justice there
was a lot of fear there
because my mind works unconventionally
right you've
you've told me this i mean like dude
when you talk you're not saying [ __ ]
i'm like really i
spent a lot of time in isolation i don't
know i don't know
um
and yeah there was like fear there like
legitimate like [ __ ] fear like hey is
this gonna make sense like are people
going to buy that i'm
shifting into all these different
[ __ ] mediums like every five seconds
but then i realized like look that's
just fear this is how my mind works this
is genuinely how my mind works
like if i'm lost in my thoughts
it is very much like guardians of
justice
so
you make it and yeah people either like
it or they don't and that's fine
whatever they want right yeah right
um
so yeah
yeah i definitely feel like that's
that's like the you know the the highest
level of martial arts for like art
that's when you're just like it's cool
i'm just making it whatever the planet's
gonna burn up in five billion years and
none of that matters whatever
i try to engage
with art
with no attachment
to the outcome but then if you're doing
that because here's the thing i was just
like yeah whatever but at the same time
like it's not whatever because you are
passionate about it you do make it
so somehow you need to like find this
balance between like this drive and this
desire
and this push because okay but
he here's where the balance is
i can control how i show up
yeah i can control the version of adi
shankar that shows up right i can
control the version of addy shankar
that is here to lead
right
i'm
not in control
of anything or anyone else right
and if i'm focused on other things other
people oh what is this critic gonna say
oh hey there's this [ __ ] troll guy
and i wanna stick it to him you know
whatever it is
i'm not in control of that i'm in
control of how i show up
that's it yeah so
i'm passionate great i can control
taking my passion and positively putting
it into a piece of art
that's
that's it
everything else is [ __ ] terrifying
everything else is not under my control
everything else is a random
series of events
that or maybe not random maybe it's an
orchestration
by a higher power
but either way i'm not in control of
that
the outcome's the same either way
outcome's the same either way
but if i focus on the task at hand and
focus on the present
then my highest vibrational self will
infuse itself into the piece of art
yeah
i definitely i get that it's a different
it's a great spot to be it can be really
hard to get there could be really scary
to get there
i feel like there's a lot of
working through it that you need to do
first before you can even be there and
then you realize that the fear
comes from the expectation
right because you get so
locked on this one outcome
and then you're like oh
i'm so attached to this outcome what if
that doesn't what if that outcome
doesn't happen
right that's the fear once you cut the
cord of that and you're like what's
going to happen it's going to happen
i'm only in control of how i show up
and if you try your best and you're
showing up as express it sounds like a
freaking school motivational video but
you try your best and you show up doing
your best
the outcome doesn't matter because you
couldn't have done any better
in a way and trust that the universe has
a plan for you
and it will it will materialize
it will materialize
you know a closed door a failure or a
failure a rejection those aren't like
these aren't bad things they just kind
of one door closes and and you've seen
this in your business one door closes
and four other
open and then you go okay these four
doors are open which one which door is
in
my highest excitement and which which
door feels most aligned with
what i want to step into and then you
step into that right yeah where you get
trapped
is if four doors open one door closes
you're in fear you're like oh my god my
career's over everything's over
oh my god oh my god four doors are open
and then you pick based on fear not on
alignment not on highest
excitement not on like what do i want to
step into you pick on fear you're like
this one this one's the sure thing
and the sure thing is usually not the
sure thing
you know yeah
yeah and then you end up doing that sure
thing when a little while later like man
this sucks why am i doing this
[Laughter]
you're not passionate about it yeah
right because again then you start then
that puts you further down the path of
focusing on [ __ ] that you can't control
because you're not passionate about the
thing you're actually doing in the
moment
you can't pour your passion into
something you can't show up as the
highest version of yourself because the
highest version of yourself would have
picked the other [ __ ] door
yeah
so why do you why do you even do it in
the first place what like what's driving
you to go out and like pursue like
making projects me yeah joy
just a joy of doing it yes i really
enjoy
doing what i do i really
deeply enjoy it
not trying to
change the world like that's not
you know the end of the day
if i have
15 shows on netflix 15 [ __ ] shows on
netflix right
guess what
people have a phone
they have a bunch of icons
one of them is an icon that within that
icon
are 15 other icons
among thousands of icons right
not changing the world bro
you're making like little dents
that
permeate
yeah in in in one shape form another
right
and we can also
debate endlessly
about the nature of creativity and the
nature of ideas and where the [ __ ] does
that actually come from right is that
coming from a higher source is that
coming from you
is it is it some sort of like
transmutation between a higher source
and your trauma that's like
co-mingling to amalgamate and then
create
a a work of art like we can talk
endlessly about that
but if it's not rooted in joy
and you and it's like a painful process
the [ __ ] are you doing dude what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah why are you
doing that to yourself
yeah you know especially when you're in
a position where it's like so many other
people want to be where you are so if
you don't like doing it
like
step away and let somebody else step in
and don't get me wrong there are
a lot of like painful moments right you
know like like uh like learning
learning is is
not easy
amassing skills aren't easy like the
the
the
the 200 300 failures you have to go
through the failures you have to go
through which are just learning lessons
in order to like get to some level of
mastery where you can kind of sort of
maybe do something right it's like a
painful it's a painful exercise right
but you have to really believe
in the
in the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow i don't mean like money i mean
just kind of like magic
life gold
like uh at the end of the rainbow
you have to really believe
in that
that that that that's that's that's joy
and that joy comes from the process
right because like
if you're fixated on
dude i'm becoming a [ __ ] preachy
[ __ ]
it's a podcast man so you're supposed to
that's what you're supposed to do [ __ ]
all right like you know like look i just
i i don't
and i'm saying this because i'm saying
this to myself because my
because my mind works in like a very
visual
you you've talked about this like like
[ __ ] very visual like i see snapshots
and like
taking a lot of information that allows
me to kind of understand the macro and
kind of see trends and and stuff like
that right
but if i let that kind of predictive
thing run me
then i'm not chasing joy i'm just
chasing trends yeah just being a
statistician effectively
yeah yeah uh
and
and yeah and then you also don't want to
be chasing like a moment
you know it's cool if you're like
writing wrestling story lines
because then it's all built about you
know like oh okay
the undertaker's gonna
hit this tombstone at wrestlemania and
the crowd's gonna go nuts because or
whatever you can
you can build wrestling around a moment
but like
yeah if you're not if the process isn't
bringing you joy
and you're just doing it because you're
like oh man i'm going to get this one
great review and then i'm going to go to
this one place and this one guy is going
to give me a high five like whoa dude
no yeah because if you just build around
moments well let's say you even hit you
get the moment you get your perfect
moment you're like yes
a few seconds later the moment's done
yeah and that's it yeah like great and
then yeah and then and then you're
depressed because you're you're living
in the you know depression is living in
the past anxiety is living in the future
so then you're like
so then you're like existing in anxiety
for this one hypothetical moment that
might never [ __ ] come
or show up the way you want it to show
up then the moment happens you get a
snap thing of joy
or whatever and you're probably like
anxious you're like oh my god i can't
believe it's [ __ ] happening
and then you're depressed because you're
living in the past you're like
remember remember that when that moment
happened everything was great that was
okay you know
yeah you know one of the things we talk
about a lot here is like consistency
like everything comes through
consistency and absolutely it over and
over which is another fancy way of
saying the process right
process and consistency are kind of the
same thing and
you know granted you in a world of like
art you're working towards an end
product
but the act of creating it should be
something that you are enjoying doing
because ideally that's something that
you're doing every day as long as you're
doing that as your career if not for
your entire life yes
and you know it's great to like build
towards your like this is my grand epic
vision and that's cool but now you're
starting to build towards that moment
where like if that thing comes out
everybody doesn't care and like five
people will watch it or whatever and
it's like well
now you're gonna be sad whereas if you
just enjoyed what you were doing every
day working with the people that you
work with yeah and like it's fulfilling
for you then it comes out it's like
great people like it and if it comes out
people don't like it it's like ah
yeah you know that sucks for me the gift
was i got to make guardians of justice
that's it
that that's literally all i focus on
yeah and i retweet when people like
tweet nice [ __ ] about it and they're
like oh my god this is a goal like great
i retweet it
that's it yeah and i'm grateful
that someone took the time to watch it
and i'm
yeah
yeah but that's
i think that's a lot of my gratitude
comes from tourism like when somebody
just takes the time to watch something
you made or to look at something you
made it's like that's really cool thank
you for doing that yeah that's it
so i think to to steer this boat away
from
these life lessons there is a good good
time we had a lot of great life lessons
here there's good stuff but you talked
about you know how you see trends and
that kind of stuff what do you see
happening right now with uh
with the art that we consume with media
you know it's like there's all these new
streaming channels you know there's
netflix netflix there's apple there's
movies maybe question mark are movies
still a thing are movies gonna be a
thing like what do you see happening in
the world around you right now
so i i don't feel like there's new
streaming channels i think these are
these are these are the incumbents
striking back
so just like hulu has obviously been i
mean apple's relatively new obviously
sure but but but but apple has existed
as an entity right for a long [ __ ]
time right
so we've got these handful of
we're effectively rebuilding the studio
system of old
right so there's going to be a handful
of
incumbent distributors
buyers
netflix hbo apple
um someone else someone else right
and
that makes sense because that's that's
kind of
where
that's where the the the ship was
heading yeah
um doesn't feel too dissimilar to
how it used to be
uh you know and then you look at like
it's all just content at the end of the
day i hate the word content but i use it
because i think it's funny
i'm like oh i'm this artist then i use
the word content
but
um
yeah it's all just content now whether
your content is like
30 minutes 90 minutes
uh
uh [ __ ] a thousand minutes it's just
it's content
yeah and it's going to live on one of
these these platforms right and i think
the delineation between tv and movies
it's kind of an archaic
an archaic thing because that was built
around
uh the two distribution platforms that
existed in the 20th century one being
the movie theater the other one being
the television that then got invented
decades after the movie theater right
yeah and so then they were programming
first for the movie theater which
you know in the beginning even had like
live orchestras there
they were figuring that model out it
didn't get crystallized into like okay
we're going to have 90 minute movies and
then we're going to turn them out and
we're having another 90 minute movie and
i'm going to have like you know
that didn't like happen until
until pretty recently like they were
still figuring out the movie thing
um
uh for
for decades
so
um
and then
tv was built around
okay this is free
it's at home it's built around
commercial breaks it's free because it's
built around commercial breaks and we
only have like three networks nbc abc
and cbs and
this is
uh
the the so there's like the movie and
then there's the
like the
the like the tv thing and then when you
cut to like the 70s sort of like in the
60s hollywood was making like these
the studio system of hollywood was
making these like
musicals like robin hood musicals these
very like kind of sanitary
basic
things and that gave rise to the
independents who started making movies
like easy writer and that led to this
entire creative revolution of movies
like the godfather and rosemary's baby
and
everything that [ __ ] came after it
right like star wars and jaws and like
everything that we we look today as like
iconic things of of the past um
and it made sense to me then why the
movie theater was the movie theater and
the tv
channel was the tv channel the tv
channel was safe right there was a there
was like an fcc that monitored what
could and could not [ __ ] go on that
thing
and the theater wasn't really a safe
place it was like kind of a marketplace
of ideas it was almost like the uh
like like voltaire and those guys in the
uh in the during the enlightenment in
the which i think like was like 1700s
kind of it's a marketplace of ideas you
go and you you're you're transported in
another world of like
either like you know in space criminals
like the past the the the future like
the wild west and
there were these auteurs who started
like telling you these very specific
stories
and that's why the delineation was what
it was and then
you know corporate america comes in in
the 80s
corporatizes the [ __ ] out of the movie
thing and then start sewing the siege of
like the the
sequels and the franchises
meanwhile
you know
tv got more complicated because you you
go from three channels to five to ten to
fifteen to like almost an infinite
number of channels
and now we're at a weird spot
because
streaming isn't tv
right
it's its own thing it's it's own medium
yeah there's no commercials that they're
trying to keep you hooked for right like
no longer like every 10 minutes a
cliffhanger happens right
or or it doesn't have to be 22 minutes
right it doesn't have to be anything
um
do i think that there's value in the
distribution apparatus that necessitates
people
showing up at a location at a specific
time to watch something in unison
together
aka the movie theater
for sure
right
but there was a law passed i believe in
the 50s i think was the glass-steagall
act
which
mandated that uh movie theaters
could not be owned by movie studios
right so they had to be separated right
monopolization thing yeah right
um and then also like agencies it talent
agents couldn't represe couldn't
couldn't also own the movie studios you
can't
so so the law was you can't
represent the talent
make the content and
distribute the content and own the means
of destructive distribution right now
interestingly enough korea
korea doesn't
have those laws so korea is completely
vertically integrated
and they it worked out just fine for
them yeah like their film industry is
[ __ ] robust it moves really fast it's
cutting edge yeah right making some
great stuff yeah in a lot of ways what
these antitrust laws did again good
intentions
but they ended up creating jobs for a
litany of middle people
that make the cost of everything go way
the [ __ ] up so i think last time we were
here
uh we talked about how
if you're warner brothers and you
release a movie in theaters the theater
takes 50 percent yeah
right off the bat which is [ __ ]
insane
but now that law has been repealed
right so
netflix amazon apple
disney
could theoretically buy theater chains
or just open their own theater right and
program however you want and then you're
no longer kind of locked in
to
a format right right like
a game of thrones type deal well [ __ ] a
new episode comes out every week
you could buy a season pass where people
are coming in every week you know what i
mean like there's there's different
models to it and i think then the
question was so in the past
like you talked like 10 years and before
the movie thing the theatrical
experience used to drive the value of
the downstream value of the content and
by downstream value i mean like okay uh
it got a wide theatrical release from
warner brothers that meant that it was
worth more on premium tv that meant it
was worth more on free tv that meant
that that it would theoretically sell
more dvds that meant that the
international distribution deals were
much higher right so the theatrical
release was this big driver of
downstream value
i don't know if that's going to be the
case
going forward because we already saw the
shift
for independent movies like
non-blockbuster movies
where the theatrical release
wasn't what was was
more of like marketing yeah for the
things right because it was more like
hey this thing's here we're gonna have
some tv spots you're probably not gonna
watch it in theaters but when it shows
up on dvd you're gonna buy it you know
yep i mean that's me that's everything
everywhere all at once right yeah i have
kids i can't go see the theater right
now all the time
but the moment it's on streaming i'm
watching it you know right yeah um
so
see i don't think any of this goes away
i think it just it just kind of
re-uh
realigns the jigsaw puzzle
um
and makes it more specific and i think
this is where
the
the anti-trust laws of of the past
kind of
stifled innovation
within hollywood mm-hmm right then you
look at the game sector they don't
really have anti-trust laws
they just [ __ ] innovate right yeah
like
like craft on can just go make pub g and
completely disrupt the entire game you
know what i mean it's like
an independent game that just blew the
[ __ ] up they're like valued now they
like ipod and they're valued at like 28
billion dollars that's more than all of
viacom combined that's more than cbs
paramount mtv vh1 you combine that
that's worth less than
one game pub g it's crazy right yeah so
yeah like
the anti-trust laws
and and a whole other bunch of factors
we got through like
stifled innovation
but what i think is also interesting is
uh here is that
um
hollywood or the movie business
is
or hollywood specifically because the
movie business everywhere else in the
world was like treated like these mom
and pop shops and it's like you haven't
really made it until you move to move to
hollywood right right um guillermo del
toro became guillermo del toro because
he left mexico and went to hollywood
right
i don't think guillermo del toro today
needs to leave right netflix goes to
guillermo del toro and gives them a
three-picture deal in mexico right
yep um because foreign language
productions are
um
well one blowing up and they're getting
global distribution and then one of them
might become squidgate so
so that's i think that's that that's
also recalibrated everything but in the
past hollywood was operating from this
culture of excess
this we are the gatekeepers of culture
we are the manufacturers of culture
[ __ ] you guys you know what i mean it
was like that kind of attitude
that mentality
um that's now shifted
everyone knows it yeah right hollywood
is not well halloween doesn't even exist
anymore because like i said it's a
handful of tech companies that are
dictating what gets made and
not everyone's congregating in the city
of los angeles hoping that you know that
they get signed to the right agent that
just this is not the paradigm we live in
anymore
so
you know we're talking about a
decentralized media landscape
that's operating kind of on a on its
back foot
where it's no longer
the cool thing it's no longer like the
de facto
uh uh cultural leader
which is kind of a dope spot because
when you when you're in that spot you
have to innovate you can't rest on the
laurels
of
the hundred plus year history that came
before it you have to innovate otherwise
it just disappears
it just goes away
what kind of innovations you think are
needed right now like is it a
storytelling kind of innovation like a
new way to tell stories is it a
distribution thing is it
like is it just a everything is now
really cheap and made for a couple
thousand people at a time like
where do you see that innovation
happening
uh everything everywhere all at once not
the movie
innovations happening everything
everywhere all at once right like you
are part of this innovation my friend
as are you
thank you you're welcome like literally
what you're doing today
right is not possible would not have
been possible
at any point in time before today right
100 right yeah what i'm doing
people did this before
may not have been as good as as i am but
[Laughter]
you know what i mean yeah um i mean it's
a little scary to think about like if we
tried doing what we were doing like we
started five or ten years earlier like
there would have been no way for us to
get our content out without somehow
convincing some executive like we
wouldn't be making viral videos to like
convince people online that we're worth
watching they'll be making videos to
convince an executive that we're worth
yeah yeah what you would have done is
because because back in the day agencies
had
um
like
like a whole roster of people who would
watch short films from students
and you and
uh uh
you and sam
would have
made a bunch of short films then one of
them would have slipped through the
cracks at the agencies and then you
would have gotten a meeting and then
someone would have signed you and then
you would have landed somewhere and you
would have made a movie right no
i i have
zero
doubt that you guys would have found a
niche
in the film industry of old right you
guys are [ __ ] talented people thanks
man and you're you're outside the box
thinkers and you guys are you guys adapt
um which i think is just really
important to surviving in any
chaotic ecosystem the ability to adapt
but um i have zero doubt that you guys
would have found your way right i think
the other way of looking at it is
because what you're doing existed it
kept you from that
right because this you're like look i
like the path i'm on why am i giving
this up to go make your half a million
dollar ghost movie that has to be a home
invasion movie because
the italian market wants home invasion
movies you know what i mean yeah you're
not gonna you're not gonna do that maybe
if we were having this conversation in
1996 you would have maybe
yeah probably honestly yeah you guys
would have been like
and probably
just kind of knowing you guys and
knowing your skill sets knowing your
interest you'd have probably
uh worked your way up through the second
unit path through the stunt you know
you've been like a stunt coordinator yep
right uh vfx again it's it's kind of a
newer industry all things considered
right so you'd have probably done the
the stunt things we've done practical
effects used real squibs exploding
squibs and done that
done that whole thing and
been second unit director on a big big
movie and leveraged that to make uh
make your own movie yeah
yeah i can definitely see that
it's crazy
definitely like you know being young and
looking at all that and be like i want
to make movies and then like
imagining what it's like and then
eventually kind of figuring out what
it's like it's definitely like a big
like a wake-up call but
it's definitely a shift in realizing
that
how you imagined imagine these projects
getting made
just doesn't necessarily align oh dude
bro i had no [ __ ] idea about anything
like i
so i questioned like all of reality
right like
i i had no idea that there was even a
camera like i was just like i thought
like a computer generated everything
you know what i mean yeah
i was like
i'm like yeah like
like you know like if a stunt happened i
wasn't like oh wow how did they pull
that off i'm like oh yeah they just
plugged it into a computer and it
created it all
yeah
man
i i can't help but feel like in 20 or 30
years it's just gonna be ai content
you know
or just like i don't think so like i
want to watch my ghost movie which is a
home invasion movie and ai's like i have
so many tropes and archetypes that can
just flesh out for you right here boom
here you go i think there's a vertical
of ai content
for sure
yeah
for sure
i mean we'll see
there's a vertical of it right but like
look
uh
furniture is mass produced by machines
today it's like massive look look at
where automation
has already over the last few decades
uh impacted
the world right like um
again it's just
like
ai
it's just another evolution of the
industrial revolution
and we've been in the industrial
revolution for a long [ __ ] time so we
have the raw data of like what happened
yeah right with other industries
and yeah so like you know furniture
became mass-produced
but
there are
still craftsmen who make like highly
specific
[ __ ]
that like people love you know yeah that
makes sense
i suppose when it comes to art like no
one's going to want to give up well
people will want their content right
yeah it's like the content i can see
that's like that's the ai yeah but you
want your artwork that's where you want
the human soul involved in it yes
yes yeah
you know and look i think there's a
version
where the ai becomes sentient
as well as well and then that gets into
the whole thing of world this thing has
a soul as well and that's also trying to
express something and then you argue
okay we've got sentient ai out there
we've got augmented humans out there who
are also making art
and then we have like old school like
neanderthal humans like you and me out
there who are also making art right yeah
and again like where does the big
[ __ ] cultural exchange happen it
happens through art
and that's the next
version of cultural exchange right it's
it's like the augmented genetically
modified brain augmented humans and the
ai
uh sentient ai and the neanderthals like
us all making art and being like oh
[ __ ] yeah i did a pretty good well i
didn't understand
that's your experience wow you know what
i mean
yeah man
i can't wait
[Laughter]
are you going to augment yourself
i already am
my skull is wrapped in metal no
uh i probably would yeah yeah why not
you know
you get to live
you read all the comic books you watch
movies when you're 10 years old like
that's cool and then like i don't know
i'll be like 70 and i'll be old my body
will barely work and i'll be like oh i
can get like new legs
hell yeah let's go
yeah
how are you
so
you know i i see like kind of privacy
issues around some of this stuff
because um
you know
like in the not too distant future we're
likely all going to have
access to an ai companion yep right so
it's like an ai bot that's either in
your head or floating around kind of
tracking all your movements all your
behaviors and being like listen dude you
don't need another cup of coffee today
it's like okay your goal is to you
should hit the gym you know what
whatever whatever it is like
kind of
guiding you
guiding you through life and i do think
that would be
valuable in in in in some ways it just
kind of comes down to like who's
building this stuff and what's the
what's the intentionality behind it
wait what's that what's the
intentionality behind it
i mean i would probably make money you
know which is i think an issue
yeah if it's if you're designing
like why would why would you invite a
salesman to be your best friend if
they're constantly trying to sell you
why would you invite a salesman to like
program your mind
right you know like and follow you
around and track all your data and
everything and know exactly how to
manipulate you you know i actually i
started writing
i guess it's a movie i started writing a
movie with this idea there's a tech
company like google they make the first
like ai friend
it basically takes over they become like
the de facto
effectively government slash you know
kind of leader for everybody
and
the ceo of this company one night
drunkenly hits a guy with his car i
guess they have the ai cars but then
whatever this is a flaw my story but he
hits a guy with his car and kills him
he's like oh [ __ ] but no one saw it
happen right
and
he basically goes to the system and
deletes all record of the sky on their
servers and since the world kind of
looks to you know it's like google like
if google wiped you from all the results
outside of the people that personally
know you you wouldn't exist right yeah
you take that even a little step for
this this guy basically erases this dude
from from life
except for you know this young reporter
girl who like still works like a
newsprint magazine it's like a hipster
thing and it was like her boss that got
killed right so like she's trying to do
some old-fashioned journalism and figure
out what happened in this mystery like
in a world that's all super high-tech
now for sure you can get [ __ ] crazy
because cause we're gonna have like
ocular upgrades and hearing upgrades
right yeah and if it's like if if if one
tech company were to presumably like run
everything
it can isolate you and say okay
every ocular upgrade no longer sees nico
and if nico talks no longer hears niko
you're [ __ ] gone like two seconds
yeah that's crazy yeah google is that's
like a crazy
but
real cause that like kind of happens
already it happens all the time already
now like i'm just not
not in like a loony sci-fi way it
happens more of a like a kind of creepy
backroom espionage kind of thing
um
and on some level i prefer the
the creepy like tech way
you know yeah
at least the creepy tech way you can
just be like whatever i'll go fishing
yeah or whatever other hobby you're into
right
yeah in your [ __ ]
um
um
yeah dude uh you know i think the future
is [ __ ]
[Music]
it's gonna be just miraculous to watch
because we are on some level
i don't think i'm similar i think on
every level we're reaching we've reached
the the zenith
the pinnacle
the maximum capacity of what materialism
and focusing on the material world
can provide us yeah as a species that's
true
i mean like right now
like right now sitting in this room
what could what material item could make
you more comfortable
i mean nothing
yeah
maybe a blanket
maybe a blanket as long as it wasn't
kind of full full of
dust and
corridor
digital sweat
and all our blankets come with authentic
or digital swords
designed to like spread it to my team to
like take them all out so that you guys
can acquire us like
you're on to us
[Laughter]
no like
yeah so i feel like this material world
thing
would ideally get sorted out on some
level before we start pivoting into like
reality defining reality pivoting
software and hardware
yeah like the metaverse
brain augmentation and ocular
augmentation and artificial intelligence
that will at some point become sentient
what's your what's your measurement for
sentience by the way we're going to go
we're going to take a little sci-fi
tournament what's my measurement for
yeah your measurement like what would
make you call an ai sentient
if they can recite rapper lyrics
so we're there if we can battle rap
within it with an ai at sentient i think
we're there all right there's something
out there
i mean arguably like
i mean we passed the turing test
multiple times at this point you know
we're there man
and look
a lot of people think thought we were
there before there because you made like
these like videos that you know like
tricked people into thinking and they
didn't
you know they just shared the video like
this is cool yep you mean the video of
the dog [ __ ] killing the dude that
miko made that was fake
that's cool the robot one
yeah make robot videos yeah no i
think we're there dude we're there yeah
we're there it's just real subtle and
like not quite as like
movie-esque so people haven't quite
recognized it yet yeah
yeah i mean
on some level how do we know that we're
sentient
we're just a fancy neural network yeah
well i also feel like we're ultimately
we're also like
i do believe that there's a there's a
soul as well there's a soul there's a
spirit
there are
there's more to your energy field than
just your physical body right like if if
you walk into a room where two people
have just had like an argument you can
[ __ ] feel the energy
uh in the room right even if you're like
what just
happened yeah um
so i do think there's more i do believe
that there's more to this than just
we're a bunch of ones and zeros in a
biological code
i do think that there's also that aspect
i do wonder about
what is this
reality and i
believe that we're in some sort of
artificial intel uh some sort of virtual
reality system simulation
i mean almost by definition yeah not
that really once again like now that
really matters because it's all you know
every day is gonna be the the same day
it's gonna be really sure it literally
has zero impact on anything and it
doesn't mean you can dodge bullets so
don't [ __ ] do that
but
you know there are other dimensions out
there there are people that can
communicate with other dimensions out
there um
yeah so yeah that's nice just a little
bit of mystery
you know
i feel like
the one thing that we saw go away in our
very very early parts of our our
lifetime like we got to see the internet
get invented right crazy right but
before that the one thing that we saw
was the world got de-fogged a hundred
percent when i say defog like you know a
video game you're playing a video around
the map and the map's foggy and as you
move the fog clears yeah and like
when we were like when you and i were
like one years old you know it's like
[ __ ] the world was still a little foggy
totally yeah oh my god that's such an
amazing way to articulate that yes
yeah
and like we would just spread rumors all
the time you know it's like oh i heard
in this place they have
yeah like
like there's dinosaurs potentially still
somewhere in the deep central part of
africa yeah
yeah like you had no [ __ ] idea
you had do you know way of knowing right
if someone said they like oh there's a
there's some tribe in australia where
people can teleport like you don't
[ __ ] know
right
yeah you don't know if the government
actually has terminators it might i
don't know
they weren't gonna tell me
now it's all defogged right now it's all
defucked yeah all defogged
that's brilliant
all defucked seemed like humankind for
years for centuries for millennia
constantly trying to defuck and it
happened
well i would say the material world has
been defucked right yeah right there's
there there is this unknown
there is something that exists
depending on how woo-woo you want to go
with it
but it's geographically speaking
geographically yeah yeah yeah but there
is something else
yeah you know like there's a do you know
that experiment where you where you like
kind of hold the water in the glass and
you say i i love you and it changes the
crystallization of the water
yeah like
i'm gonna sound like a like i'm
completely making this [ __ ] up so i
would encourage you to like look this up
or anyone to look this up but this is
the thing
like the molecular structures of water
changes
depending on what intention you put into
it
interesting
um
you have to google that look it up
so there is kind of more
to even the material world then
uh
the material world would have you
believe
i think i think taking a little mystery
into the end of this podcast is probably
the best way to
wrap it up
so
let's let's roll with that love that all
right cool well everybody that was audi
that was a great conversation man i
[ __ ] love talking to you i like
talking to you too i like that we have
the excuse of i love you too dude and
i'm glad we have the excuse of like you
know microphones and cameras to like
just let us sit down and chat yeah just
feed the ego you know what i mean i was
like
i said some dope [ __ ] and it got
documented
but in all honesty for everybody that's
listening and watching this podcast
really appreciate it thank you for
tuning in hope you guys enjoy it love to
hear people's thoughts down below you
know in the comments that's like my
favorite things to make comments and see
the discussions going on i also brought
three outfits today and nico picked this
one yeah it was the coolest looking one
like i said leisure athletics totally
like i'm athletic but not right now what
would tony stark wear i'm in between
workouts
yeah totally
my first workout was two months ago my
next workout's in about two months so
i'm in between workouts right now it's
amazing i had a lumberjack outfit
uh a ryan gosling and drive outfit and
this wow yeah would that be like italian
the tracksuit mafia yeah from hawkeye
there you go
european f1 fan love you love you too
dude thanks for coming out
uh yeah thanks for listening everybody
see you guys in the next one thank you
bye